yes as you say a 16 year old boy
arrested at 5am this morning at an
addressed in Huddersfield remains in
custody today
arrested on suspicion of Kyrie McLean's
murder an attack which happened just
before 3 P.M yesterday afternoon at a
time when there were many school
children still on this stretch of road
today we have seen parents pupils people
that knew Kyrie and people who just
wanted to come and pay their respects
laying flowers sharing tears and just
remembering this boy who was attacked so
brutally at the school which is just
moments from the place where Kyrie was
receiving medical attention
remained closed today but it said its
doors were open to any pupils who wanted
to come and who needed support and
indeed we've been speaking with people
in this local area and of course
something that happened so shocking so
brutal in the middle of the afternoon
has left many people deeply worried and
very very frightened we spoke to one
mother whose children are eight and five
who told us that this is well she
thought it was a very safe area and now
she is very very worried and concerned
for them but that significant
development today from West Yorkshire
police of that arrest of a 16 year old
boy in connection uh on suspicion of
Kyrie's murder Kyrie McLean's mother
coming to this scene earlier today as
you can imagine absolutely devastated by
what has happened and that is a
sentiment shared by certainly Kyrie's
girlfriend who also came supported by
family members to lay flowers here the
school itself issuing a statement saying
that it was devastated giving its
condolences of course to Kyrie's family
and his friends but also saying that
they are deeply shocked and devastated
at the loss of a boy that they described
as with wonderful people